bonjour bouëx et clara guissény révèle
un bon plan entier ennuis pendant le
confinement
[Musique]
alors un jeu je sais pas si ça peut être
considéré comme un joueur mais je me
suis mise au coloriage livre de
coloriage et les collèges pour adultes
quand c'est pas facile mais je vous
montrais mes skis féminin
en tout cas ça détend serait quand on
colorie en concernant d'autres
[Musique]
l'artiste que j'écoutais qui met de
bonne humeur pendant le confinement
c'est c'est toujours le même artiste
comme moi je suis une fan hystérique de
paul mccartney donc je suis fidèle à
paul mccartney pendant qu'on filme j'ai
relu shining
alors certains diront que c'était une
bonne idée de voir des trucs angoissant
pendant le confinement et je le conçois
mais moi c'est vraiment un de mes films
préférés notamment pour l'esthétique et
je laime je commence à connaître par
coeur mais c'est toujours agréable de le
revoir c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
[Musique]
en ce moment une série que je dérange
c'est camions cars et enthousiasme avec
la 8 bits que j'adore qui me fait
beaucoup rire et je crois qu'on a besoin
d'un peu d'humour et de légèreté ce jour
sinon c'est une série que je vous
recommande jeudi au niveau de nos côtes
ce qui est je viens de lui lire en
anglais ce qui est une grande fierté
pour moi parce que je parle anglais
comme une vache espagnole et du coup ça
a été beaucoup de travail je suis
content parce que le confinement c'est
bien pour ça aussi pour prendre le temps
de faire des choses qu'on ne comprend
pas entendre que vous lancer des défis
en entrevue je vous donne un exemple de
ce que j'étais avec mon ami théodore a
choisi ensemble à un tableau à
reproduire et on s'est donné cinq jours
pour le faire et j'avais jamais cette
aquarelle de même avant mais j'ai
toujours eu un poids et donc là je ne
sais pas du tout terminé et c'est un peu
un peu machine en temps fou on trouvait
sur 7 sur cette aquarelle donc ses juges
et aux graisses conseil l'a peut-être de
challenge et vos amis sur sur des choses
créatives